例えば瞑想して心の働きだけ見られるようになったとする
そうすると体を見ていない物体を
その人はどう感じるかというと
体が消えたんだと 感じるのは心だから
あれは体が消えたんではないかと感じる
そこで体が消えた なんだこれはと思った瞬間で違う心が生まれるわけですね
体認識しようと それで体が認識する
それでまた体が消えたという感覚が消えちゃうんですね
そういうのはものすごいインパクト
強くわかるようになるんです
それで そういうことは何かありがたいこと
それは仏教の瞑想世界で
そんな経験は全然無視するんです
あんた何を経験しているんですか？偉そうにしゃべったって
まあそう それだけで終わっちゃうんです
そこでは科学的だから
仏教はそこであなた体が消えたことを経験したんですから
素晴らしい人ですよと
じゃあ免許証書いてあげましょうとかね
ちゃんとそんなことはないんです
それで科学的なことだから
そこで理解してほしい法則があるんですね
やっぱり一つ認識するともう一つは認識しない
それだけ だから至るべき結論というのはすごいつまらない結論なんです
せっかく何十年も瞑想して
やっとすごい境地に至ったのに
それぐらいですかということになるんです
だから だからそれは解脱の道なんですよ
執着しない道だから で
それで心の法則はそこら辺で見えてくる
知恵ある人には見えてくるんです
光が見えた すごいんだとか
神々見えてきたんだ すごいんだとかね
体があの 何といいますか
浮いてるような感じがしました
素晴らしいとかね やったぞとか
そんなこのガキの話ですか
幼児的なことはヴィパッサナーの世界ではもうないんです
その代わりに 知恵のある人が何がわかるかというと
これはこんな働きかと
心っていうのは いわゆる体の重さとか何とかとか
認識しないで他のことに忙しくなったらこれなくなっちゃうんです
ただそれだけのこと 四十キロの体重ある人が瞑想したところで
体重が零に感じる感じたということは
その人の心がもう体のことを心配することはしてないと
他の仕事で忙しいんです
それだけ 体重消えたわけでは何でもないんです
本当に消えてないかと分かる
分かる 理解したければ科学的にやらなくちゃいけない
ちゃんと体重計に座って瞑想が始まる
そこで他の人に頼んで
時間と体重計のメモリをきちんと記録してもらう
そうでないと証明できない
仏教はそれを厳しいんです
そこら辺では 自分にとっては私の体重が軽くなったと零の状態になりましたと
ということで それに神秘的な解釈説明はもう評価しない
その中で科学的な発明
ひらめきがあってほしいと
そこをなかなか人間に難しいんです
だからお釈迦様の言葉からちょっとあの厳しく
あの 厳しく非難してもらわないと
で そういうことで この瞑想とかなんとかいう特別訓練しないで
この心の働きは見えてこない
心というのは この何か
例えばAというものを認識すると B
というものは認識しない B
というものを認識すると A
というものは認識しない
そこで因果法則の立場から言うと A
を認識する心にはBを認識不可能なんです
それわからないというならば
例えばこの何て言いますか
ものを作ってもらう場合は
我々いろいろ道具使うんですね
例えば天ぷら作ってるんだと
これを天ぷら油に入れたものはもう揚げてきたら
もう一つ一つ取るともう揚げすぎだから
いっぺんに取りたいんですね
それであるものを道具を持って
それで全部取って入れておくと
それで一緒に味噌汁も作ってるんだと
それで味噌汁を入れようと思って
同じものでカップにカップというじゃないね
あれ 茶碗ですか それに味噌汁って入りますかね
入りません あれ 網だから
だからそれには決まってる仕事があるんです
他の仕事には使うことはできません
それで味噌汁を入れるあの匙で天ぷらあれ取ろうと思ったら
油と一緒に出てくるんだから
もうむちゃくちゃもう大変なことになるんですね
そういう同じことで A
というものを認識する心にはBというものの認識はできません
だから ものを見る心と音を聞く心は違うんだと
そこで心の働きっていうのは一回一つしか仕事しないんですね
それは瞑想で経験として表れるはずなんです
一回一つの仕事しかしない
そこら辺でどういう答えが出てくるんですかね
それだったら すごく厳密に客観的に
ものすごい論理的に考えないと
生ぬるい考え方はもうできません
仏教では そこではっきりとわかるのは
やっぱりある瞬間で一つしか認識しない心が
そこで次の瞬間で他のことを認識する
でも同じ心にはそれ不可能なんです
不可能でしょ だから A
を認識する心にはBを認識できませんだから
そこで一つの瞬間で一つのものしか認識しない
心というのは認識する働きなんですね
心の心っていうのは それでAを認識する瞬間で
これからBを認識する心が寝ているんですかね
寝てないんです もしAを認識する瞬間で
これからBを認識する心があるならば B
を認識しているんです
心があるということは
何かを認識していることなんです
私に心があるということは
私は何かを認識しているんです
感知しているんです 感じているんです
だから 一つの瞬間で一つしか感じることできないということは
一つの瞬間で一つの心しかないということなんです
それで次のBを認識する瞬間で前の心がないんです
もう死んじゃったんです
そこでBを認識する心はAを認識した過去の心
とは違うんです そのように心の法則なんです
そこにアイデンティティがないんだと
私というもの だからずっと体の説明でも言ったのは同じことですよ
今ここにいる私は 私の両親が原因ではないんです
本当は両親には何の権利もないんです
あんたは私の息子や娘やという権利が
あれは嘘ですよ 私はあなたをお腹痛めて産んだんではないかと
嘘を言うなと あなたを産んだのは別にもうこんなでっかいから
産むところか 生まれ 産んだ人が母親二人ぐらいでも抱っこして持ってるぐらい力ありますから
体もでっかくて それじゃないでしょうし
全くの別人なんです アイデンティティがないんです
それでなぜ我々はアイデンティティを作りますかというと
この流れということなんですね
そう 流れ この流れだけの流れというのはただの言葉であってね
それに騙されているんですね
母のお腹の中で何か物体が
目に見えないほど小さい物体が出来てきて
それはどんどん それはまあ
それはどんどん大きくなるんじゃなくて
そこは変化して変化して
体の外に出て また勝手に自由自在に変化していく
体から一旦出ていったところで
もう別に自分で変化していくんです
おっぱいあげてもあげなくても
産んだ赤ちゃんがもう成長するんです
だから産んだその瞬間からもね
他の方法で栄養をあげればいいでしょうに
母親のおっぱいを必ずしもあげなくちゃ死ぬということはないでしょうに
だから結局お腹の中の成長にしたっても
別に成長させることができます
すごい小さい時でも もう細胞一個でも
あの 何て言いますか 試験管ででも成長させることはできます
ということは依存してないということなんです
物質は別なところから来るということなんです
だから大変残念ですけど
そちらにそういう関係ないんですよ
我が子という それで それでも私たちは自分の母親が私の息子やと娘やと言うんですね
なぜ言うかというと この流れでしょう
この流れだから 責任感も道徳観も全てが成り立のであって
実際する何か永遠的な実体あるんだからではないんです
だからあくまでも無我は無我なんです
実体はないんです そこでみんな我々に文句の実体もないのに
どうやって私はいいことをしたらいい結果が得られるんですか？とかね
私は死んじゃったらどこで生まれ変わるんですか？とかね
そういう質問にはもう答えられません
もう もう何十年も厳密にこの科学的に物事を勉強するならば
そこに答えがあるんです
答えられません 私が死んで私が生まれ変わるわけじゃないんだから
今ここにいる私が母親のものじゃないんだから
ただあるのは流れという
説明しようとするならばフロー
フラックス それだけ だから
そういうふうに理解できるということは
知恵の世界でね 普通の人間には全くできない
もう感情だけで生きてるんだからね
感情だからね 私の母親は本当に苦しんでるんだ
なんとか 悩んだりするんですね
いろんなことで怒りやら嫉妬やら苦しみやらね
人はあらゆる苦しみ なぜ生まれるかというと
この私がいるというこういう考え方あるんだからなんです
その考え方自体を間違ってるんだと
科学的に見てみなさい
何もないんだと  そういうふうに考えて
とにかくこの心の働きにまた戻りますけど
心の働きも同じことで
物質とも同じことで 全くもう別なものを取ってこちらで大きくなるだけで
別なもの取れば取るで前の古いものは捨てなくちゃいけないし
そこで実際にまるっきり違う人物なんです
産んだ母ちゃんと二十の人物っていうのは
一つも似てる細胞はないんです
形に似てるかもしれませんだけど
コピーするんだからね
ある細胞が死ぬ場合は
外からもらった他の物質で新しい細胞を作るでしょうね
作る細胞はこの細胞のコピーなんです
コピーはと原稿というのは同一ものですかね
コピー機械でいっぱいコピーするでしょうね
原稿を入れてコピーする
それで原稿イコールコピーですかね
似てるだけでしょ 何一つも異可能なもの
何一つも原稿からコピーに行ってないんです
紙も違うし そちらに付いているあのカーボンも分子も違うし
でも私たちはそれを見て似ているんだから同じというあの大雑把ないい加減な無責任な言葉を使うんです
だからそのコピーシステムですね
だから仏教は理解しようとするならば
いとも簡単なんで 我々毎日使ってるコピー機械でやってる同じ働きがこの体でも起きてるんです
うん そういうことで この一つの絵を認識する心が心にできるのは絵を認識することだけ
それで次の瞬間 瞬間に B を認識するんだから
その時はあの前の心の代わりにこの心死んで
その代わりに他のコピーが生まれるんです
次のコピー だから B を認識する心がおそらく A を認識する心のコピーです
でもこの場合はコピー作ると原文で
なんて言いますか 元のものは死ななくちゃいけないんです
そうでないと現れないんです
だからコピーと違うところはそういうところ
[背景の音]だから一つ壊したいんだけど
壊す前に壊す場合はそれ壊しますけど
一応その形をとって新しいものを作ると
伊勢神宮でやっているような感じで
年経ったら神殿を壊して新しいものを造る
全く似ているんです だからまあそういうふうに当たら
だからこの心にも流れがあるんですね
だから物質はものを認識しませんだから
ものを認識する働きは心だと別つに理解する
別つの働き 別つのエネルギーだと
そういうところで人が生まれたっていう瞬間っていうのは
認識が現れたっていう瞬間である
物質には認識する能力はないんです
どう見たってもないんです
だからどう言えばいいんですかね
我々はどれぐらい研究
どれぐらい科学を発展したっても
こういう何かにいきなり命が入ってしまって
物事を認識し始めたっていうことはありえないんですね
SF の世界では そういうコンピューターなんか自分で考え始めて世界支配したとかとか
もうもう何て言いますか
もうムービーとかはあるかもしれませんだけど
でもどう考えたっても
あれは論理的には不可能なことなんです
自分で判断するっていうことは
物質には そういうわけで
まあなんかちょっと問題が起こるんですね
だから初めてある物体の中で認識機能が現れると
その物体自身が起こすわけじゃないんです
そういうわけで 仏教では輪廻っていう考え方があるんですね
そのエネルギーは似ている
前の似ている前のエネルギーから出来上がらないと
論理的なんです そこら辺も仏教の輪廻の考え方
だから理解できるかできないか別の話で
それはこの簡単単純な論理の説明するためにはすごい長い間勉強しなくちゃいけない
それでこの依託 依託ですか
依託縁というのは その
そういうことなんですね
例えばある心が死んで次の心が現れますね
やっぱり コントロールされるんですね
コントロールされるもんだから
それは例えば 例えばもう人間の性格っていうのはどうやっても直らないでしょう
いくらこれ論理的じゃないと言っても
性格直らないところあるんですね
すごい基本的なところで
ものの見方 生き方とかね
直らないとこあるんですね
例えばもうだらしない生活をしている人がいるんだ
その人にはものすごく説教して
説教して 論理的に 合理的に
もうあんたは非論理的なことをやるんだから
これから論理的にやりなさい
はい 分かりました 明日からしっかりだらしない性格やめますとと言ったら
あまりにも説得力って言ったならば
1日 2日  3日  1週間  2週間ぐらいはしっかりするかもしれませんだけど
またズルズルズルズルと元の生き方に戻っちゃうんですね
そういう風にこの どうしてもこの心のこの動く
この変化しているこの方向性っていうのは
そう簡単には変えないんですね
なんかコントロールしているんです
そこは神様にコントロールしているとか
そんな話ではなくて それは依託の因縁ですという
わかりやすく言うならば
今馬鹿でいる私が心は瞬間瞬間変化していくんだから
次の次の心で天才的な心が生まれたきたんだと
ある日突然天才になったってことはありますかね
ありえない 逆はありますけど
だからこの例えばもう物事を理解するのはすごい遅い人がいるとすると
その人は死ぬまで遅いんですね
理解することが ある学生が
まあこれもう子供たちに教える時はね
その心の働きっていうのはすごく勉強できますからね
で 同じ授業を聞いている子供たちの中で
ある子供はもう一回でわかっちゃう
だから何かを理解してもらうために
一つの子供にはもうほんの 2 3 分もかからない
隣に座っている子には分かってないんだと
あんた分かってないでしょ
じゃあもう一回言いますと
それでも分かってない
で これみんなに迷惑だから
また授業終わってからちょっといらっしゃいと
もう自分のところに来てもらって
まあ 1時間ぐらいかけて説明したところで分かりましたと
ある子供にはもう 2 3 分もかかってないんだけど
もう一人の子供には 1時間ぐらいかかっちゃうんですね
そこでそこで分かったんだから
教えた側も良かった その子も分かったんだから
また次からまた簡単に授業できるんだと思ってはいるんだけど
また次の授業を始めたら
また前の子が 3 分で分かっちゃうし
その後これまた首を曲げちゃうんですね
また同じ時間かかっちゃうんです
大変なんですよ この子供たちに教える場合は
もう真面目に教えようとしたら
自分のクラスの人々はみんな同じレベルで合格してほしいと思ったら
これすごい苦労なんです
それその その人のスピードが違う
スピードが違うのはいいんだけど
それは時計の問題だから
もう理解の仕方がまた違うんですね
同じ科目にしても それぞれの理解の仕方がまた違う
そこはなぜかと やっぱりそのその体が持っている心の流れなんですね
心が一つ生まれて それ死んで次の心が生まれる
それ死んで次の心が生まれる
でもその 流れの流れの方法違う
まあ噴水の例えだっても同じことでしょうね
だから同じ水道管で水を出て行って噴水になったとすると
やっぱり最初に水が噴水通して出た瞬間で
この水の流れが決まってしまっちゃうんですね
例えば水が外に出る穴がちょっと横に向いてある
ならば 水が横にしか出れません
これ上は上がれません
まっすぐに空いてる穴穴から出る水がまっすぐに行ってまっすぐ落ちると
そこで穴の大きさによっても
水の流れが変わっちゃうんですね
もし穴がまん丸ではなくて三角だったら
またその噴水の形が変わっちゃうんですね
だからほんの一瞬間だけなんで
その変化が起きるのは
水道管から出ていく水がこの外へ出る瞬間でだけその影響を受ける
それからずっと水が落ちるまでの変化の方向性をそれで変わってしまっちゃうんです
そのように我々にとってはやっぱり
ずっとあるんでそれを
それはイジクの因縁ですね
だから業の結果からは
人間にはもうどう頑張っても逃げられません
ずっとついて回るんですね
そういう意味だと思いますけどね
まあこちらもそんな説明はないし
これはイジクの因縁ですね
次はユタパッチャ で イジクシンどこに働くかというと
例えばこの生まれる瞬間でどんな心が生まれるかという
あの噴水と同じ 最初の心にはイジク
それはイジクシンなんです
前の何かの業の結果として現れる心だから
それからその体で死ぬまでその方向性で流れなくちゃいけないんです
で アハラパッチャ アハラパッチャっていうのも
まあこれも何でしたっけ
今 食因 まあ食っていうのはもう
そんなことはまあすぐわかるでしょうと思いますけどね
まあ私たちは知ってる食べ物
食べ物しか食としてを考え
アハラというのは食べ物という意味なんです
アハラの意味がこの 何といいますか take
inという意味なんです
アーハラティという言葉からできているんです
ハラティっていうのは
まあハラティだけだったら
take away take
outという意味になっちゃいますけど take
なんです Take 英語のtakeもあまりよくないんだけど take
取るという意味ありますけどね
まあとにかくaというのはinですからtake in
だから玄関にある荷物はtake in
それでファストフード屋さんに行ったらTake outでしょ
アハラティっていうのはtake inという動詞なんですね
それから作る名詞がアハラ
動詞からいつでも名詞作るんだから
だから食べ物には簡単にアハラって言うんですね
そこでまた厳密な説明に
ものすごい厳密にややこしい
うるさいほどの厳密な説明にはどうしても行っちゃうんです
アハラっていうのはもう大根やとかね
ジャガイモという そんな風には言えません
定義必要なんです だからtake inだけでアハラという定義にはならないんです
玄関にある何か荷物を家の中に持っていくこともtake inですけど
それアハラ 食べ物ということにならないんですね
食ということにはならないんです
食べ物っていうのは定義として見れば
そのある何かを壊れてしまうんですね
それ壊れてしまうんだから
その欠けていく部分は外から入れてまた修理するんですね
壊れないと それなんです
だから そういう厳密な定義で行かないと意味がわからなくなっちゃう
アハラというのはやっぱり何か
例えばもう仮に何かものがある
そのものがその状態でいられない
そのものが作ったもの
そのものをどのように成り立たせているかといろいろ原因成り立ちますから
そのものがどんどんどんどん欠けていっちゃうんです
欠けていっちゃうと これ壊れてなくなっちゃうでしょうね
それで欠けていく部分は外からまた入れる
入れてまた形を守る それにアハラと言うんです
そんな難しいことじゃないんで
我々はもう 1 日中仕事をしたりすると
たくさんエネルギーはなくなるでしょうに
だからまあ ジャガイモやらおにぎりやらいろんなものを食べてエネルギーを入れるんで
そんなもんなんです 食べなきゃ死ぬんです
はっきり言っているんです
エネルギーは出ていくと壊れてしまうでしょうに
確実に死にます だから死なないためにいろんなものをずっと入れているんです
その働きは分かります
そこで次に次のステップ
これを理解してほしいんです
この形が壊れないようにと
我々の場合は 私が死なないようにと食べているんだと思っても
どうなるんでしょうかね
例えばある形のものを作る
その作ったもののエネルギーがどんどん出ていく
出ていくと その形が壊れようとする
そこで新しく入れる 入れたら入れても
また出ていく また入れようとする
入れると一応形が守っているようには見えますけど
同じものですかね 全く違うものなんですね
もっと即的な子供に分かりやすい例で言うならば
例えば 200個のブロックで私たちは何か
あの 何でもいいんだから何か作ったりする
箱を作ったりする そこで 1 分経ったらあのブロック 1個を捨てなさいと
その代わりに違うブロックを入れなさい
というと ブロックだから
あのブロックというんですか
あの子供たち遊ぶあれ
それいろんな色あるでしょ？赤やら青やら黄色やら白色やらなんとかとかね
色は別に考え そこで 1分ごとに 1つ捨てて
ただ 1つ入れるだけになっちゃうと
まあこれ 200個ありますから
200個分というと まあ何時間ですかね
一応 まあ 3時間ちょっとですね
で 同じあれ形ですかね
全く別なブロックでしょうね
その場合は それでもあまり気にしないんです
気がつかないんです それでも例えば 1個のブロック
青いブロックを捨てて赤いブロックを入れたんだからといって大胆な変化があるわけじゃないし
そこで黄色いブロックを捨てたところで
子供はもう適当に白いブロックをそこに刺したとすると
別に大胆な変化はないんだけど
一旦写真を撮ってでも見てみたら
すごい変化がそこにあるんです
だからそこにはアイデンティティがないということを理解しているんです
だから 仏教専門用語で使っているこのアーハラというこの概念自体がもう大変なもう概念なんです
そこでも何を使用するかその自我がないということ
永遠不滅なものはないんだと
それでも流れていくんだ
だからこの体の場合 我々理解しないのは
この 私たちはね 中華料理食べて
和食食べて元気でいるんだとかね
そこら辺は因果法則じゃないんです
体には中華料理も和食もいりません
中華料理いるんだったら
どんな人間でも黒人でも中華料理食べたら中国人になるはずでしょうし
黒人が和食食べちゃったらもう 1年以内でもう日本人になるでしょうし
そうはなりませんだからね
体に何が必要かとも医学の世界でちゃんと説明してるでしょうし
炭水化物やらね もうそれからプロテインって何でしたっけ
うん タンパク質やらね
ミネラルやら水やらね
そういうものなんだよね
必要なのは だから我々はもうおにぎり食べて元気ですよっていうことは間違いであって
やっぱりそれはもう簡単にわかるでしょうしね
もう炭水化物やらタンパク質やら
そういうものを体にとってるだけですから
消化っていう働きも必要なんで
そこで工場ですからね
そこでちゃんと工場で
このあんた 和食食べようか
中華食べようか そんなことは関係ないんだと
でお腹の中で全部アイスクリームと味噌汁とご飯と全部一緒にね
チキンとね 食べたハンバーグと全部一緒に混ぜるんです
混ぜて体に必要なものだけ取るんです
だから我々のこの食文化っていうのは
本当に体から見れば完璧に無視されてるんですけど
完璧に無視されてるんで
とにかくそこで 細胞の中から見れば
やっぱりそちらはやっぱり体で作れないアミノ酸やら
それでエネルギーに必要なものやらね
それはずっと必要ですから
それだけとって 入れ替えて入れ替えて入れ替えていくんですね
その次元で考えちゃうと
私たちは本当に変化するんだっていうことがわかるはずなんです
細胞は この私たちは哲学の哲学者のふりをして和食を食べてるんだとかね
中華食べてるんだとか
そういうことで喋って考えてるんだから
変なことになるんですね
それでケンカまでするんですね
世界で一番美味しいのはどっちですかとかね
個別差別なんだかんでもするんですね
それ全くもう無知な世界の話で
体にはそんなものは何 1つも要りませんね
で 体に必要なのはもうすごい単純なもので
その単純なものが細胞が入れて古くなって壊れていくものはもう捨てて
そちらからも何か必要なものあるんだったら
それを入れて新しいものを作っていく
だからブロックの例と同じなんですね
それでも みるみるうちに私たちの体が新しく生まれ変わっているんです
そこでこのブロック入れ替えるのはもう子供だから
結局 例えばしっかりと作った何か形が置いておいて
じゃあ